pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur jean pierre barbier
madame la présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre et j'y associe mon
collègue alain moyne bressand monsieur
le premier ministre la commune de
moirans situé en isère a été hier le
théâtre de scènes de violences et de
guérilla urbaine
inadmissible et inexcusable au prétexte
d'une décision de justice défavorable
quant à une permission de sortie de
prison pour des obsèques des individus
se sont livrés à de véritables actes de
guerre civile durant plusieurs heures
voitures brûlées bâtiments publics
saccagés routes et voies ferrées bloqué
mairie a siégé c'est la terreur qui a
réuni à moirans je veux rendre hommage
aux habitants aux riverains pour leur
sang froid de même que je veux rendre
hommage aux élus locaux au maire de
moirans qui a dû faire face seul dans
les premiers instants à ce déchaînement
de violence
des remerciements aussi aux forces de
l'ordre sapeurs pompiers qui sous
l'autorité du préfet sont intervenus
avec efficacité dans un contexte
extrêmement tendu pour ramener le calme
et la sécurité sans qu'aucune victime ne
soit à déplorer
monsieur le premier ministre rien ne
justifie ce qui vient de se passer et
les auteurs de ces actes devront être
recherchée et condamné la justice et
l'état ne doivent pas plier un défi est
lancé depuis quelques mois à la
république par des minorités et sans
faire d'amalgamé
je considère que toute contestation par
la violence d'une décision de justice
qu'elles concernent des enjeux
environnementaux sociétaux n'est pas
acceptable et ne devrait pas ouvrir de
droit au dialogue
sinon demain ce serait légitime et la
violence et ce serait l'anarchie qui
régnerait dans notre pays
j'ai entendu des déclarations de
condamnation et de fermeté du
gouvernement
elles sont conformes à une attitude
républicaine que je partage mais au delà
des déclarations
ce sont des actes qu'attendent
aujourd'hui les français et les
habitants de l'isère sur ce cas
particulier mais aussi de manière plus
générale etes-vous prêts monsieur le
premier ministre a adopté cette attitude
de fermeté sur l'ensemble des dossiers
qui ces derniers mois ont émaillé
l'actualité
je vous remercie merci n'a pas envie
d'être premier ministre madame la
présidente monsieur le député jean
pierre barbier mesdames et messieurs les
députés l'état la république c'est
l'autorité ce sont des mots mais ce sont
des actes aussi qu'ils doivent suivre
vous avez raison l'autorité de la loi
l'autorité des décisions de la justice
monsieur jacob le ton de la question de
monsieur barbier ne mérite pas vos
interruption emerich une autre attitude
ce qui importe c'est le maintien et le
respect de l'ordre républicain et je
vous réponds bien sûr très directement
les décisions de justice s'applique
partout à moirans en isère comme sur
l'ensemble du territoire
j'ai d'ailleurs hier répondu à une
question la manière la plus claire
possible sur notre dame des landes par
exemple les petits troubles ayant eu
lieu hier à moirans à voreppe en isère
et au centre pénitentiaire d'aiton en
savoir sont par leur gravité
leur violence inexcusable et tout cela
choque légitimement nos concitoyens et
comment pourrait-il en être autrement
il est intolérable qu un déchaînement de
violence quelle que soit la raison soit
commis au prétexte de contester par
ailleurs une décision de justice
la seule manière légitime de le faire
c'est d'user dé voir drogue qu il ne
peut pas y avoir d'autre attitude
hier après midi le gouvernement par la
voix du ministre de l'intérieur a
immédiatement donné les instructions de
fermeté aux préfets afin que l'ordre
républicain soit rétabli vous le savez
des unités de forces mobiles ont été
dépêchés sur place et elles resteront
sur place autant que nécessaire le
gouvernement veut féliciter les
gendarmes les policiers les agents
pénitentiaires madame le préfet qui on
est en qu'il n'y ait de blessés qui ont
agi avec sang froid
grâce à leur maîtrise
fessionnels je veux saluer comme vous
l'avez fait aussi monsieur le député le
maire de moirans et ses équipes et tous
les habitants qui se sont retrouvés face
à ce déchaînement de violence
ceux qui veulent tordre le bras à la
justice tordre le bras aux forces de
l'ordre
tord le bras à la république s'expose à
une réponse d'une extrême fermeté et ils
doivent s'attendre
ceux qui ont agi hier à être
implacablement recherchés et poursuivis
en justice
monsieur le député
pour ce qui est de moirans hier comme
aujourd'hui et jusque devant les juges
d'appel
les magistrats auront des décisions
fermes dans un contexte difficile
complexe qui rappellent s'il le fallait
la difficulté de leur mission et je les
assure aussi de l'appui total du
gouvernement pour que les décisions de
justice puisse être rendue dans la
sérénité comme elles le doivent
et sans que l'ordre public le soir mais
prise en otage
nous répondrons avec la plus grande
fermeté avec les forces de l'ordre avec
la justice c'est-à-dire aux piliers de
l'état de droit
face à ces violences merci la parole est
à mme